TSB has taken down its mobile app and
online banking service following a
botched IT upgrade and apparent data
breach will the announcement was made by
the company's chief executive Paul
pester as part of a personal apology
following days of disruption that has
left a camp holders in the dark over
their finances the chair of the Commons
Treasury select committee Nicky Morgan
told Sky News she's written to the bank
demanding an explanation
well we've asked here's me a series of
questions we'll wait for their answers
if necessary we can obviously summon
senior management chief executive
downwards from TSP to come and give us
evidence we will contact the financial
conduct authority - I'm sure they will
already be on the case and very
interested and then of course there may
well be wider lessons to learn for the
security of online banking which we're
all being encouraged to use more and
more Paul pester joins me now Paul good
evening to you what do you make of what
Nicky Morgan said there well you know
we've just completed the biggest bank
migration in Europe so we've moved five
and a half million customers off of the
old Lloyds Bank I plant for them onto a
new platform and for the vast majority
of customers in the vast majorities of
ways the bank is running smoothly and
I'm not trying to downplay some of the
issues we've had on our digital channels
but it's very specific our website and
our app have been unable to cope with a
large number of concurrent users that
we've seen there are no issues on
security let me be crystal clear there
are no issues on data there are no
issues on any of those sorts of aspects
this is about enough bandwidth in our
platform to cope with a number of uses
we have some tendency so we've taken the
app down we are making some fixes and we
expect it to be up again soon so are
these systems not tested adequately
prior to the migration well you know
we've spent two-and-a-half years
building a new banking platform we had
to move off the Lloyds platform you know
we had a 10-year contract you'll
remember that this all came about
because of Lloyds having to divest ESB
the testing was very extensive we have
had nine different cycles of taking date
data from Lloyds running it through the
new platform it's very hard to actually
recreate exactly how customers are going
to use the platform in terms of direct
debits standing orders debit cards
credit cards payments all this stuff is
working
smooth
we have an issue on the ability to
manage enough customers online
simultaneously so when are you gonna
have the online services restored I'd
love to think they will be up very soon
potentially as we're speaking in but
certainly this evening I would like to
see them up what I have said to the team
is don't bring them up until they're
ready the last thing I think our
customers want is for us to say
everything is now working we obviously
apologize for this but everything is
there working come and login and then
find issues so I'm desperately trying to
get to a point where this app and the
website works reliably for our customers
so potentially this evening but possibly
even into tomorrow we will I'd love to
have it up receive me we are working 24
by 7 as I say this is the biggest bank
migration Europe's ever seen
we've only 5 and 1/2 million customers
1.3 billion pieces of data from Lloyds
we have our teams working on it and I'd
love to see it up and running this
evening what about the penalties that
you face now I mean the FCA is probably
going to be rattling the bars on this
RBS when they had a similar data breach
we find 70 million pounds are you braced
for similar sort of punishment we
haven't had a data breach what we have
seen is our website not being able to
cope with the volume of traffic we're
having now of course we're talking to
the FCA we're talking to the PRA both
the SCA and the PRA have been involved
with us on this on this journey for two
and a half years as we've built and
tested a new platform so they're very
familiar with everything we're doing and
of course we're keeping them right up to
speed you've said that everyone will be
compensated who's lost out on that yes I
mean let me be crystal clear any
customer that is out of pocket as a
consequence of our issues we of course
will put them right there's a link on
our website so if their customers go to
our website public website which is
running very smoothly there's a form
they can fill in please let us know if
you tweeted us we of course will try to
respond by Twitter but you're much
quicker getting hold of us through our
websites and what about but I mean that
could even include potentially people
whose hash Pierce purchases have been
derailed on you could be looking at some
large individual payouts here our
mortgages have been running very
smoothly you have no trouble whatsoever
completing our mortgage applications our
mortgages have been running on the new
platform for several months now so
mortars are not a problem ATMs are not a
problem
debit cards are not a problem just to be
clear all these payments are running
very very smoothly
it's about getting access to the website
and I have and serving enough customers
simultaneously oh it's gonna roll for
this well we all I'm focus on at the
moment is serving our customers you know
TSB has made a fantastic reputation for
serving customers where the most
recommended high street bank in britain
we're here to try to break the
stranglehold of the big five banks which
we think have been shortchanging for
consumers for far too long
we look forward to launching into
business banking so we are focused on
our mission to bring more competition to
UK banking what about your bonus and
those of other executives you are you
gonna suffer financial loss for this
that's the decision for the remuneration
committee and the board that's for them
to figure out what I'm figured out is
providing a great service to our
customers well you could volunteer to
forego it yourself couldn't you I don't
decide it anyway it's up to them to
decide so the board will decide the
Remco will decide what I need to focus
on is providing outstanding TSP service
to our TSP customers what are the
lessons do you think that have been
learned from this was it too early to
say we know one of the lessons is just
how difficult it is to really be a
competitor in the UK banking market the
big five banks control between 90 and 95
percent of the market we had to move off
the Lord's platform we had no choice as
a consequence of Lloyds receiving state
aid and it just shows how challenging it
really is to take on there's enormous
big five banks that controls so much of
the market we are using this new
platform to launch into small business
banking that market is controlled by
five banks there is a lack of
competition in those markets I look
forward to speaking to Nicky Morgan
about what the Treasury select committee
can do with banks like TSB to break the
stranglehold of the big five banks and
actually make banking better for small
businesses and UK consumers but after
this why should anyone have confidence
in TSP well as I say if you look at how
the bank platform is working for the
vast majority of transactions the vast
majority of customers I'm not trying to
downplay the issues we've had but for
the vast majority of transactions and
customers things are running very
smoothly trying to move five and a half
million customers trying to move one
more three billion pieces of customer
data from one bank platform to another
and then flush it all through and have
it
working is very challenging no one has
done this before I apologize profusely
to our customers it must be incredibly
frustrating to hear someone like me
saying we're trying to get this fixed
believe me I want to get it fixed but as
soon as we get it fixed we will have
bringing TSB back to her customers
expect us to be
you